what is grief
if not love
persevering
part of the madness of the multiverse is
we get to see different realities and we
see different versions primarily of
doctor strange but we do see other
versions of wanda maxima
i think wandavision was this journey of
her for the first time taking her own
life into her own hands and it was fun
transitioning from her experience to
this movie you could use an avenger
there are other avengers i'll get you
back on the lunch box
what do you know about the
multiverse we wanted to satisfy the one
division fans
and take them to the next level with a
character they loved
it was fun just looking at it from a
different perspective
the multiverse
this had his theories
he believed it was dangerous
we need your help
it's magical she owns that character so
well it's a very powerful performance
with a very powerful character in the
multiverse there are alternate versions
of everyone it gives the characters
unique opportunity to meet themselves
to recognize qualities that they may
have been blind you
the fate of the multiverse depends on us
[Music]
what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and we have yet another
new trailer featurette from marvel
studios today marvel studios has been
releasing a ton of new trailers with a
ton of new footage for doctor strange
and the multiverse of madness including
some pretty decent sized spoilers like
yesterday and this morning marvel
studios released an official tv spot
that showed us a look at professor
xavier's gold chair and they showed us
captain peggy carter and you have to
think they're showing us these cameos
only in the tv spots what further cameos
await us inside the actual movie it's
definitely super exciting so let's go
ahead and break down this new footage
that we got today a lot of new footage
containing the scarlet witch and i think
they might actually give a clue here on
why wanda is going to actually be the
true villain kind of the reason behind
her motivation to go on her rampage so
let's dive into it and of course if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
videos so this new featurette from
marvel studios is titled wanda returns
and it actually starts off with the
voice of vision he hits us with his
famous line that he told wanda in one
division what is grief if not love
persevering telling us that grief is
going to be a big part of wanda's story
in multiverse of madness but this we
already knew yes wanda is going to be
grieving because of the loss of her kids
but i think some of us are forgetting
vision the trailers really focus on her
kids including this trailer but this one
focuses a little bit more on vision as
well now in this trailer we actually get
some narrative from kevin feige himself
and he says that part of the madness of
the multiverse is that we get to see
different realities and we see different
versions primarily of doctor strange
talking about different variants but we
do see other versions of wanda maximov
now in this featurette we actually see a
lot of footage of wanda with her kids
and she's at her old house kind of
frequently now we know from the official
trailer that these are dreams that she
is having however they look to be pretty
real meaning that wanda is actually
going to believe that they are real
until she actually wakes up from this
dream but it kind of might be a thing
where it's getting kind of hard to
determine dreams from reality and this
could actually tie into the end credits
of one division where wanda is studying
the darkhold and she hears the voices of
her kids that combined with her having
these dreams almost visions that seem
real could be the reason why she starts
to explore the multiverse in search for
her kids now kevin feige mentioned
variants of wanda and in this trailer
and in other trailers we actually see
wanda with her own variant and i think
that this variant is up to no good now
wanda is not supposed to be the scarlet
witch the scarlet witch is not supposed
to exist according to agatha harkness
and if they kind of stick true to the
comics a little bit there should only be
one scarlet witch throughout the entire
multiverse meaning every different
variant of wanda is not going to be a
scarlet witch they'll be powerful but
not the scarlet witch that is arwanda
which is why i actually think one of
these variants of wanda could be coming
to our wanda and nobody knows you like
yourself so i think this variant is
actually going to manipulate our wanda
into kind of tearing apart the
multiverse going universe to universe
killing people killing the illuminati
doing whatever they can to get her kids
back i've mentioned it before and i
still think it's true i think that
darkhold is going to be manipulating her
just a little bit almost tainting her
with an evil spirit i think this
combined with an evil variant of wanda
is kind of what sends our wanda over the
edge and makes her kind of go on this
killing spree to do anything to get her
kids back and vision because they
actually show vision quite a lot in this
trailer we even see footage of wanda
having to kill him in avengers infinity
war so the grief is still a very big
thing yes we went through it in one
division but it is not done for wanda if
anything it's about to get a lot more
stronger again to the point that she
would do anything to get her family back
now sam raimi speaks in this trailer as
well and he says that this movie is
going to give characters the opportunity
to meet themselves and recognize
qualities that they may have been blind
to now that can go both good or bad
there could be some great qualities that
you didn't realize you had that kind of
are brought out when you see a different
better variant or a worser more bad
variant of yourself could make you
realize hey i have some of that in me
too and it's not so good and wanda is
extremely powerful most likely the most
powerful being in the entire multiverse
and a bad quality that could come with
that is the ability to kind of just do
whatever you want because nothing can
get in your way for example we have a
new scene here of the scarlet witch
actually several new scenes of wanda
attacking the carmitage and doctor
strange and wong and the rest of the
sorcerers in fact if you freeze frame
right here in this new trailer you can
actually see as wanda shoots up into the
air she is leaving from the carmitage
and it is on fire and in destruction in
the background and we actually see some
new scenes of her flying through the air
throwing out attacks i'm assuming
against the carmitage again because
we've seen the scene where the entire
karma taj all the sorcerers are looking
up into the sky and we've seen scarlet
witch in the sky so that has to be right
before she attacks and judging on these
scenes she attacks from the air goes
down fights on the ground and then she
leaves probably once she defeats
everybody now there is one very peculiar
scene in this trailer at the very end it
quickly flashes between different
versions of wanda some of these may be
the same some of these may be variants
it goes from her at her house where we
see her with all the trees to her and
her scarlet witch crown to her covered
in blood which i actually think is a
variant then it shows her in her house
and she slowly turns and looks at the
camera could she be breaking the fourth
wall here now it's a multiverse film
anything is possible in fact they could
even acknowledge our universe in a very
very funny way they could pull it off i
don't think they will but they could but
she is clearly looking into the camera
here and it makes you wonder if she's
gonna kind of pull a deadpool this is a
true office fashion look into the camera
moment and briefly speaking of the
office fingers crossed john krasinski
shows up as mr fantastic but why would
she be looking into the camera well
she's either going to be breaking the
fourth wall in some way shape or form or
perhaps she's just simply turning and
looking at somebody and that's the way
the camera decided to shoot it but i
really hope it's actually breaking the
fourth wall here i think that would be
really cool in a huge multiverse film
but a lot of these new scenes were of
wanda which makes sense the trailer was
titled wanda returns but i actually
think we saw several different variants
in this trailer and i do think it's
going to be an evil variant of wanda
that's going to be causing a lot of
problems for our main mcu wanda
hopefully at the end it comes down to
taking down an evil variant of the
scarlet witch and rwanda remains good in
the mcu but let me know what you think
about that in the comments down below is
that something you want do you want her
to turn good at the end or do you want
her to stay evil let me know don't
forget to like the video and subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest mcu and doctor strange 2 news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
me